[Music]
janet starts off this hour in pittsburgh
hey janet how are you i'm great how are
you
better than i deserve what's up better
than you deserve i know it i've been
listening to you and following
since um the 90s but went through
financial peace
yeah yeah back in 2009 and again in 2012
when i was living with my husband we
paid off 167
000 in debt but got right back in
i separated from him 16 months ago
got a restraining order and the kids and
i have been living on our own since then
i have two at home out of six wow um
the other four are grown up so i'm 56
i earn including child support about 57
five a year i have two jobs uh
one is i work for a person with autism
as an aide
and another one is i work in an
emotional support therapeutic classroom
as a paraprofessional the second job i'm
not crazy about there's a lot of danger
there
and i'm getting older um so
i paid off my last debt my car on
thursday of last week
um yes and so i'm debt-free
yeah and then i took the rest of the
money from the settlement from the house
that we sold
during this huge market boom we sold the
marital residence and i put the rest
and funded my baby step three good so i
i feel like i took
two huge steps and i don't know quite
what to do there's still some money left
over i'm putting it in a
fund to save up for a down payment for a
house
perfect i'd like to move from pittsburgh
and move back home
or someplace where they have fantastic
jobs like you guys do
okay where you don't have to worry about
a kid carrying a switchblade into school
i got you you know well that's pretty
well anywhere these days but yeah
okay so i'm i'm done with funding
college and all of that that's
you know my daughter is probably going
to go into the air force we don't have
to worry about that
my son that lives with me pays rent and
i'm trying to figure out and have
everything budgeted
i just want to figure out how to do this
house thing right without screwing it up
because i'm going to be going back into
debt and i just got out of debt
so i want to do it you know i'm thinking
maybe a fifty thousand dollar house
maybe eighty where is that home that
you're talking about moving to oh
erie pennsylvania all right and uh
mistake on the lake and can you uh
uh buy a house for fifty thousand
dollars in erie pennsylvania
you still can but the problem is the
challenging thing is the employment
market
okay all right that's that's the thing
now my one job will go with me
but my other job you know that's 23 000
worth of income that i have to replace
really with what i do
that's not who is an eerie better than
that
i have family there but mostly it's the
familiarity it's
um you know i could go pretty much
anywhere
but i don't have another landing pad
that's what i was um i have a girlfriend
who lives down in north carolina but the
rate of living there is so expensive and
i don't think
that my second job would transfer down
there
if the job situation need working i'm an
aide working for my son
and that's funded in pennsylvania so i'm
golden in pennsylvania
yeah janet was going to ask you really
quickly is if the eerie job situation
was just a snap it was already taken
care of
would that be your favorite place of all
the places you could go yeah
okay so so how much
extra money if we remove the second job
where you're in the classroom is
essentially a parapro
how much money do we need to replace on
that particular job how much
23 000 okay i could drive a bus
you know and make more than that there's
a lot you could do yeah so let me ask
you this and i don't know
the thing that that gives me summers off
with my son i have a 21 year old son
with autism
gotcha so ideally you want the summers
off
so what could you do yeah well that's
ideal correct
all right so here's what i'm trying to
walk you through i want you to have an
ideal list okay so
ideally if i could get a job in the
school system that's not as scary
as the pair pro and these in these
classrooms uh
with some of these kids that's ideal but
then we say okay let's look for what's
there
let's just not assume that as well it's
a horrible job market in erie the
mistake by the lake it's what you call
it you've kind of pooh-poohed the whole
area so let's see what's there that's an
idea
yeah i know uh and so well let's look at
ideal and then we look at okay
what could i do that would still give me
a life and my 21 year old son
i mean i'm going to work 40 hours and
make really good money i can make more
than 23.
and i think you've got to ask yourself
what can i do well let's just start with
the tools
we look at talent here at ramsey
solutions as a
tool that i can use to do work that i
enjoy so start with
hey i'm really organized i'm really good
with people you need to just do a quick
assessment
and and i want you to go to kencole.com
and get the career clarity guide simple
little worksheet
it allows you to get feedback from
people who know you really well so you
get some confidence on this
but just begin to identify another day
job that you can do well
that's in a better environment and now
you're there with family
you're saving up and you're you're
getting that house a lot quicker than
you realize but don't assume
that something's not there until you dig
into it because there's a lot of work in
area that she can do dave
and make more than 23. yeah continue to
save on your baby step 3b
for a down payment on a house when you
move to the area you do not have
to buy a house immediately you can rent
for a little while
and let's get all these career boxes
checked
and your income and even support boxes
checked and maybe north carolina is
there that's right um
i will tell you there are sections of
north carolina that are less expensive
than erie pennsylvania
so your set of assumptions there is just
not accurate
so you've assumed that everything in
areas bleak and horrible including
prices on houses
and then everything in north carolina is
the land of uh
you know plenty and and expensive and
it's
neither one of those is completely true
there are some
good spots that you can pick in erie and
land in and some good jobs that you can
pick there
and the same would be true of north
carolina and so these blanket statements
now i do think the reason you're wanting
to go to erie and what familiar is after
going through this divorce
and all this pain you want a familiar
place to heal
and i'm perfectly okay with that idea
that's fine the familiarity part of your
statement was absolutely truth
that was very good so you know begin to
find something
make a move there is nothing if you go
rent and get a job
there's nothing to say that you don't
find a better job in a different place
later and move again that none of this
is none of these are forever decisions
so you got to get on a path here
that gets you um you know heading
in a direction of a career and a house
and i and those are not incongruent with
where you are i think you can get there
i really do
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple a eight two
five
five two two five when you're faced with
a set of
decisions like they can we teach
decision making is in one of the
leadership things in entre leadership
um there's a couple of things that that
uh
that when you get emotional
whether you're wounded angry whether
you're
hurt whatever emotion you want to put
out there
you shut down your peripheral vision and
you fail to see as many
options for the way around something you
get tunnel vision
and options the more options you have
when you're making any decision the
better likelihood you're going to make
the right decision
when you start saying absolutes like
there's no jobs there
or that's area is just always expensive
these are absolute statements that are
inaccurate
and that's coming out of your pain